in this video I want to talk about
another form of enzyme regulation called
covalent modification specifically a
subclass of covalent modification called
reversible covalent modification there's
another video on a reversible
modification in actually the next video
so if you recall allosteric regulation
was sort of this idea that enzymes could
be regulated by the concentration of
effectors near an enzyme right so
basically the idea there is that Alice
tech regulation is very it's pretty
instant right it's instant and rapid
based on what's going on in that enzymes
environment if there are if there are
inhibitors there then they will inhibit
if there are activators there they will
activate it it's as simple as that and
that happens right away right if those
if those effectors are around that
enzyme covalent modification is a little
bit different its first of all it's a
very very common form of regulation but
the effects are usually slower and last
longer okay they're slower and last
longer then allosteric regulation and
covet modification is actually really
really important when we think about
signal transduction which we'll talk
about in a later video so there are two
types of covalent modification there's
phosphorylation and dephosphorylation at
least is the data to that we're going to
talk about so want to talk about the
definitions of these two things
so the function as far as what is what
is phosphorylation phosphorylation is
simply adding a phosphate group which I
will represent with a P and a circle
okay so a phosphate group D
phosphorylation is removing a phosphate
group so now where are these phosphate
groups added and/or where are they
removed from okay so the target is
really just any hydroxyl group okay if
it's theirs if there's a there's an O
age group okay that's the that will be
replaced right this will these hydroxyl
groups will become a phosphate groups
and I'll kind of draw that and
you know that's represented but hydroxyl
groups so same thing here hydroxyl
groups I mean now here when we're adding
a phosphate group to an alcohol target
alcohol specifically I want to give you
have you keep in mind the idea that
which which amino acid residues have
hydroxyl groups right like like tyrosine
serine and threonine right
they all have oh wait groups on their
side chains those side chains can be
phosphorylated that's something I want
you to keep in mind okay
so how would a hydroxyl group become a
phosphate group the way it would could
be drawn to be represented it would look
something like this so instead of an ROH
it would look like this you have an R o
P O 3 to negative and that would
actually look like this
specifically the P and then three more
OHS okay so these two negatives here
that's how a phosphate group would look
and this would have to happen on an O
age group right which could be on a
tyrosine a serine or threonine okay so
now with fall there are two different
types of enzymes that can actually do
phosphorylation and there's only one
that I'm going to mention that does
dephosphorylation so a phosphorylase is
a type of enzyme that will phosphorylate
things it'll add a phosphate group now
specifically phosphorylase is what they
do is they add they add the word it's a
matter of where they get their phosphate
they add a phosphate group or excuse me
not I want to write their add an
inorganic phosphate group which is just
a phosphate group from the environment
okay
from the cell kind of just floating
around okay so where as second thing the
second type of enzyme that that uh
actually before I mentioned the second
type let me give you a quick example an
example of a phosphorylase that we're
going to talk
in just a moment is glycogen
phosphorylase we're not going to talk
too much about it but I want you to just
keep it in mind as an example glycogen
phosphorylase so the other type of
enzyme that you know undergoes
phosphorylation as the phosphate group
is a kinase or a kinase whatever people
call these kinase what they do is they
also add a phosphate group what makes
them different from a phosphorylase what
they do is they add a phosphate group
from ATP or another or another
nucleotide drop nucleoside triphosphate
okay okay
usually it's ATP though generally
speaking that's how I'm going to source
it I'm going to sort of associate the
word kinase with adding a phosphate from
an ATP as opposed to just adding an
inorganic phosphate whereas so an
example of a kinase example of kinase is
hexo kinase which is a the first enzyme
in glycolysis and what it does it's a
kinase and it adds a phosphate group to
the HEC so hexo means six it's actually
going to add a phosphate from ATP to the
sixth carbon six carbons o age group
we'll see that later in the video on
glycol this was that but the thing is
this name makes sense right and that's
something to bear in mind phosphatases
phosphatases are not the exactly reverse
of a kinase but what they do is they
remove a phosphate via hydrolysis they
remove phosphate groups by adding water
which is hydrolysis they hydrolyze the
bond so this is how you know this
covalent modification is reversible
right we can make the covalent bond to a
phosphate group we
so remove it by just adding water so
that's the whole idea behind this
covalent modification being reversible
okay so now I want to mention something
I can actually write it down but within
kindnesses there are particular try this
is called like protein kinases we'll
learn about those more when we talk
about signal transduction which I
mentioned up here another thing I want
to mention is that this this bond here
right that we have between this o and
this p is a phosphate ester bond notice
that this was a carbon here this would
be considered an ester bond right but
now or an ester linkage but here because
the phosphate is considered a phosphate
ester linkage okay
and also there's also protein
phosphatases or phosphoprotein
phosphatases not something terribly
important just now but an example of a
phosphatase is glucose six phosphate
phosphatases actually the enzyme that
does the reverse step of XOXO kinase so
XO kinase adds a phosphate from ATP to
glucose right the sixth carbon of
glucose whereas glucose-6-phosphatase
catalyzes the reverse reaction which
removes that phosphate removes the
phosphate off of the sixth carbons o h
okay and of course again via hydrolysis
okay so I hope that makes sense there
and how it's reversible so let's talk
about this quick example of glycogen
phosphorylase and how these kindnesses
and phosphatases sort of come into play
so if we think about glycogen
phosphorylase we wrote here excuse me
more on this later is in short though
it's an enzyme that catalyzes the
breakdown of glycogen into glucose so if
we think about glycogen phosphorylase
this is the enzyme let's just write this
representation of the enzyme this you
can imagine this enzyme and it's here
right and we can
this is this will be what we'll call it
the app the unactive form or the
inactive form okay the inactive form
specifically is glycogen phosphorylase
be write inactive or at least in the
least less active okay kind of sort of
like in it in a tea steak so um so what
happens is we can activate it by adding
these phosphate groups okay so this this
glycogen phosphorylase over here is
active or at least more active
so this glycogen phosphorylase is
actually like fusion phosphorylates a so
adding these phosphate groups how did
they get there well there was this
enzyme phosphorylase kinase let's see if
this name makes sense
it's a kinase so it adds phosphate
groups that makes sense we took this
collection phosphorylase and we added
these phosphate groups so the make sense
it's a kinase and it's a phosphorylase
kinase which means it added the
phosphate groups to phosphorylase which
is this enzyme this enzyme is glycogen
phosphorylase so but where did it get
these phosphates from specifically you
got them from ATP so if this is the
reaction arrow heading towards this
glycogen phosphorylase a then we must
have added some ATP specifically we
added two of them right because we added
two different phosphate groups
so we've input two ATP's and we get out
to ADP s right because once we take off
a phosphate from the adenosine
triphosphate then they become die
phosphates right to catalyze the reverse
reaction we have a different enzyme a
phosphatase so the phosphorus this is
phosphorylase phosphatase so it's going
to be the enzyme that removes phosphates
from phosphorylase from this glycogen
phosphorylase by adding water so here
we're going to input water and then off
pops those two inorganic phosphates oops
that's kind of ugly okay 200 phosphates
so this reaction up here we inputted two
ATP's to get to attach those two
phosphates to make an active form and
then here we added water to to hydrolyze
those bonds and go back to this inactive
so depending on whether or not we want
to break down glycogen for glucose we're
either going to activate like a do
phosphorylase or deactivate it so in
cases where we want to break down
glucose we want this form so we would
want this enzyme to be active so that it
can activate like it's in phosphorylase
but if we don't want to break down
glycogen if we want to store glucose as
glycogen we want to make sure that the
end the the phosphorylase is inactive so
we would add water to to hydrolyze those
bonds via this enzyme in block this
enzyme to be active to make this one
inactive okay one thing I want to know
is that it's not always the case that
phosphorylation activates a protein
sometimes adding phosphates can
deactivate it it just depends on the
protein okay so that's something I'll
just note here is that note
phosphorylation does not always activate
a protein it can deactivate a protein it
just depends in the protein one last
thing I wanted to mention I mentioned
that these phosphate groups had to be
attached to hydroxyl groups okay now in
the case of glycogen phosphorylase these
two phosphates were added onto
particular age groups those age groups
were serine residues okay so I want to
note that as well not that's terribly
important but it's just something you
know keep in mind these were both
attached right to a serine residue right
right because serine has a no age group
in its side chain okay so I hope that
was helpful and I'll see in the next
video